the last time I saw you you were painted
red and you're ordering people to go
meet the collector what can you tell us
about guardians of the galaxy very
little of course otherwise I'll be I
don't know what put in a cell somewhere
I can tell you that there's more of the
same that kind of vibe going on I am
terrified we've ever liked saying the
big bass let's be part of the excitement
of all the mystery rounding and the kind
of how ambiguous surrealism right you
know because so many people have read
the the graphic novels the actual films
there always are kind of an intrigue to
see how they've been interrupted and
what aspects the dress has chosen to
focus on and yeah and Marvel often sign
their actors down for loads of films and
there's crossover with other characters
in other properties there any superhero
you'd like to be in a film with from the
Marvel Universe like see you in an Iron
Man film earth or anything like that
oh wow that's a really good question I
don't know all I really don't know I I
did I do love thought I did I do love
the whole kind of the tone of everything
of that I don't I don't really know
where I'd fit in I know one of your
former co-stars know where boy Aaron
taylor-johnson he's Quicksilver now and
Avengers would you like to work with him
again
I would love darling and he was huge
and lastly Carina your character can you
tell us anything about your character -
and who she kind of has scenes with in
the film my scenes are with Benicio del
Toro and Zoe Saldana
Benicio tho ok thanks very much for
talking to us it's been brilliant I'm
really looking forward to the film thank
you yeah I know me too I'm Antonia
you